The success of our VQE algorithm heavily
depends on the state and circuit
we choose to begin with.
I'm Victoria Lipinska and in this video
we'll explore the options
we have in designing them.
Let's take a closer
look at all the elements
we have in every run of the quantum
part of the VQE.
We begin with the reference state,
sometimes called initial state.
We run the reference state
through a parameterized circuit called
a variational form
with an initial choice of parameters,
and we measure the state
in the basis of the Hamiltonian
after running it through the circuit
to obtain the expectation value. Now
we'll walk through each of these elements,
starting with the reference state.
A typical choice for the reference
state is the zero state.
That is the state in which a quantum
computer is already initialized.
For quantum chemistry problems,
one can also use the so-called
Hartree-Fock State,
which is the result of a Hartree-Fock
method.
In a nutshell, Hartree-Fock
theory gives a simple way to construct
the reference state by approximating
the ground state of a quantum system.
It finds a rotation
within the space of states
that minimizes the ground state energy.
Finally, the reference state
can also be very problem specific,
and you may want to choose
a custom state.
In the case when you know what properties
your system has, for example, symmetries
or a specific number of electrons
in the state, you can use that
to have better convergence of the VQE
algorithm.
Choosing a good reference
state is important for convergence
reference states that are close to
the ground state
can make the problem converge
much easier and faster.
Similarly important
is the choice of initial parameter values
that we feed into the variational form.
Therefore, depending on the reference
state and initial parameters,
we may converge quickly, slowly
or not converge at all.
Let's look at this plot
and for visualization purposes,
let's imagine that our space of parameters
has only one parameter.
A very good reference state
can allow you to start very close
to the final ground state
and then convergence will be fast.
On the other hand, if you start very far
from the ground state here,
reference state
a, you will have to cross a high energy
barrier leading to a very slow convergence
or no convergence at all.
We will discuss this in more depth
in the classical optimization module
in this course.
Let's now look at the parameter circuit
that acts on the reference state, a.k.a.
the variational form.
When this circuit, the know,
the U of theta acts on the reference
state,
it produces what we call a trial state
psi of theta or sometimes ansatz.
It is this ansatz state that is
then measured in an appropriate basis
to obtain expectation
value for the energy.
The variational forms
that we're discussing here
are motivated by chemistry.
However, keep in mind
that there are also those inspired
by quantum machine learning
and other near-term
algorithms like quantum
approximate optimization algorithms.
Let's discuss
some common choices for a chemistry ansatz.
Unitary coupled cluster or UCC
is the method originally proposed
in the first VQE publication,
and it's commonly used in quantum
chemistry problems.
Typically,
when we parameterized a quantum state,
we work with exponentially
many parameters.
However, to make preparation
circuits efficient,
we need the polynomial number
of operations
and therefore a polynomial number
of parameters.
UCC is an example of a way of preparing
a trial state with such a circuit
and it derives from a coupled cluster
method,
which is the golden standard in quantum
chemistry.
The most common choice is the unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz or UCCSD in short.
Because UCCSD is motivated by specific
electronic configuration of a problem,
we need to ensure we have a reference
state which properly reflects the system.
This is the Hartree-Fock state.
UCCSD ansatz usually gives
a good approximation of the ground state
because it captures single and double
electron excitations in a given molecule.
The number of parameters in UCCSD scales
quadratically with the number of spin
orbitals.
UCCSD can be very well
tailored to a problem,
but unfortunately, quadratic scaling
still leads to very deep circuits
which are difficult for current quantum
computers.
This is why IBM researchers proposed
more heuristic approach,
where one can tailor a variational form
to the underlying hardware
which results in an efficiently
executable circuit.
That is, trial states are parameterized
by quantum gates
and are adapted
to the available physical device.
This is a very heuristic approach
that is hardware friendly.
Based on these examples, let's take a look
at the spectrum of possibilities
that we have to express
our variational form.
A lot of these
are already implemented in Qiskit
so I encourage you to try out for yourself
which one is the most suitable
for the problem you're trying to solve.
If we look at the graph, on the one hand
we have the very heuristic
variational forms.
When the problem specificity is low, but
they are designed to be implemented
on the real hardware.
They are also highly expressive,
all in the sense
that one can express
many quantum states with them.
However,
a problem that may occur in the later
stage of classical optimization
is encountering
the so-called barren plateau,
which we will discuss in the next module.
On the other hand,
we have a highly problem specific unitary
coupled cluster, which works
excellent in classical chemistry but
is difficult to implement on the quantum
hardware because of large circuit depths.
Generally, calculations
can be more successful if you can,
first of all choose a reference state
and initial set of parameters
that create an ansatz state
close to the ground state.
And second, avoid unnecessary parameters.
These either introduce
greater circuit depth with no payoff
or create a larger parameter space
to search leading to plateaus
in the classical optimization.
What parameters are necessary is a problem
specific question
that requires careful thought.
Let's talk about where our guest of honor,
the Hamiltonian, is hiding in all of this.
As we learned in the previous section,
the Hamiltonian after qubit
mapping is represented as a sum of
weighted strings of Pauli operators.
Eventually, however,
we want to evaluate the expectation
value of our Hamiltonian on the ansatz
state produced by the variational form.
Luckily, quantum
mechanics is nice and linear
and this is what we'll use
to get the expectation value.
This is how it works.
We know the Hamiltonian is a weighted
sum of Paulis
because of linearity
the expectation value of the sum
is equal to the sum of the expectation
values of each Pauli string.
Well, this is great because as you already
know, measuring in the Pauli basis
is as simple as a rotation
of a standard measurement basis.
Instead of measuring the expectation value
on this huge Hamiltonian represented
as a sum, we first evaluate expectation
values of individual terms
and sum at the end
with corresponding weights.
This is why in many resources
you will see only single qubit rotations
after the ansatz.
This is what implements the Hamiltonian
in every execution of the circuit.
In the next video,
we'll explore what happens
during the classical optimization step.
I'll see you there.